hi everyone
this is professor mda science and today
i want to talk about the relative motion
of two
interacting quantum particles in another
one of our videos
on rigorous quantum mechanics if you've
been following our videos for a while
you may have noticed
that all of our videos on the postulates
of quantum mechanics
or angular momentum or the quantum
harmonic oscillator
they all focus on problems with a single
quantum particle
so today we're going to take a very
exciting step forward and talk about
what happens when we have
two particles this will provide the
foundation to study one of the most
iconic potentials in all of quantum
mechanics
the hydrogen atom which is made of a
proton and an electron
what we're going to learn today is that
quantum systems of
two particles can actually be solved
with what we already know
about quantum systems of a single
particle this is because we can apply a
very convenient change of coordinates
that will take us from our system of two
real
interacting particles to another system
of two fictitious particles that don't
interact and we can then treat these
two non-interacting particles as two
individual
single particle systems so let's go to
set up the problem
let's start with a coordinate system
before we do anything else let me
emphasize that our discussion will be
general
and apply to particles moving in a
three-dimensional space
but for clarity and simplicity i'm going
to draw
two-dimensional diagrams let's consider
a particle at position r1
with mass m1 and another particle at
position
r2 with mass m2 the focus of today's
video
is to study two particle systems such as
this one
in particular we're going to focus on a
very common situation
which is what happens when these two
particles interact
fire a potential v that only depends on
the relative
position of the two particles so we can
write it as
v of r1 minus r2
two particle systems are very common and
many of you will have encountered them
before
in the context of classical mechanics
what we'll do today is to explore the
corresponding quantum two particle
system
and we'll find that we can effectively
rewrite it as a system of two fictitious
particles
that do not interact with each other
something that greatly simplifies the
maths
today we're going to look at the general
properties of two particle systems
but moving forward one key system that
builds from this video is
the hydrogen atom in which these two
particles
are a proton and an electron and
their interaction is described by the
coulomb potential
so i encourage you to check out all of
the videos
on the hydrogen atom afterwards
if we start with particle one then in
quantum mechanics we have three position
operators
and three momentum appraisers
i'm using the subscript one to indicate
that
these operators are associated with
particle one
as always the position and momentum
operators obey the canonical computation
relations
which we have along the first direction
along the second direction and along the
third direction
and any other commutator involving
operators associated with particle one
vanishes similarly for particle two
we have three corresponding position
operators
and the three corresponding momentum
operators
we also have the corresponding three
non-vanishing commutation relations
along the first axis
the second and the third one
and again any others involving particle
two operators
vanish any mixed commutators involving
an operator associated
with particle one and an operator
associated
with particle 2 also vanish
to put it another way we have 12
operators
grouped in threes here here here
and here then all commutators between
these 12 operators vanish apart
from these six commutators written down
explicitly
here and here
to make progress we're now going to
define two new sets of coordinates
the first are the center of mass
coordinates
i label them with a capital r and define
them
as the mass weighted average of the
original coordinates
pictorially we can draw a coordinate
system again
place particle one here and particle two
here
and the center of mass coordinate is a
mass weighted average of the positions
of the two particles
so for example it would be somewhere
between the two particles
here and this example corresponds to
particle one being heavier than particle
two
so the center of mass is closer to
particle one
if you're familiar with classical
physics then you will recognize this
definition
if you've not encountered this before
don't worry
you can simply take this as a definition
and what we will discover today
is that the center of mass is a very
convenient way of describing
two particle systems in quantum
mechanics
before we move on and just to be
absolutely clear
this operator capital r is in reality
made up of three separate operators
capital x capital y and capital z
each of these in turn is defined in
terms of the original coordinates for
example
x is equal to this
the second set of coordinates we need to
define are the relative coordinates
we're going to label them with a
lowercase r and define them
as the relative vector between the two
particles
note that i'm using lowercase r's for
all of these coordinates
but when i have a sub index one or two
they refer to the positions of the
particles
and when i don't have a sub index they
refer to the
relative positions of the two particles
so keep this in mind
if we make some room in the above
diagram then the relative coordinates
define
this vector and just like for the center
of mass coordinates
the relative coordinates are an operator
r made of three separate
lowercase operators x y and z
and as an example the x operator is
given by this
we can easily invert these definitions
to write the position of particle one
in terms of the center of mass and
relative coordinates
and the position of particle 2 also in
terms of these new coordinates
and i will leave the proof of these
expressions as an exercise for you
let's now turn to momentum and we'll
start with the definition of total
momentum
to motivate the definition let's first
consider the classical setting
classically we would define the momentum
of the center of mass with a capital
p and set it equal to the total mass of
the system
multiplied by the time derivative of the
position
of the center of mass where this dot
indicates the time derivative we can now
expand
the total mass as the sum of the masses
of our two particles
and using the definition of the center
of mass position we get
this second term we can now cancel this
term
with this term and end up with m1 r1 dot
plus m2 r2 dot this is simply the
classical momentum of particle one
and this is the classical momentum of
particle two
by analogy we'll now define the total
momentum operator
in quantum mechanics we also label it
with a capital
p and set it equal to the sum of the
individual momenta of the two particles
and again remember that this is in
reality a collection of three different
operators the next quantity
as you may suspect by now is the
relative momentum
in classical mechanics we label it with
lowercase p
and set it equal to mu times the time
derivative of the relative coordinate
this mu here is called the reduced mass
and is given by m1 and 2 over
m1 plus m2
we then also have the time derivative of
the relative coordinate
reorganizing this expression we get this
and now this time in brackets is the
momentum of particle one
and this term in brackets is the
momentum of particle two by analogy we
will now define
the relative momentum operator in
quantum mechanics we also label it
with a lowercase p and set it equal to
the classical expression
where the mentor are promoted to the
corresponding operators
and again just keep in mind that this is
in reality a collection
of three different operators we can
easily invert these expressions to
obtain the momentum of particle one
in terms of the center of mass and
relative momentum and
in a very similar way we can get the
momentum of particle two
in terms of the new momentum variables
and i'm going to leave the proofs of
these relations as an exercise for you
to try out
as we already discussed earlier if
you've encountered these relations
before in classical mechanics that's
great
but if you haven't don't worry you can
simply take the various equations as
definitions
and we'll find out later in the video
that these definitions
turn out to be very convenient when
working with two particle systems
okay so we've had enough definitions so
let's recap
we're studying a two particle system and
to describe
it we have used this collection of
operators associated with particle one
and this collection associated with
particle two each of these operators is
made
of three components so we have a total
of twelve
operators then we have defined
a new collection of operators the center
of mass
operators and the relative operators
and this is simply a change of variables
and as expected we still have
12 appraisers overall we can describe
our system with
either set and then relate them together
with the appropriate change
of variable formulas
what we will see today is that this
second collection of
operators is the most useful to describe
a system of two particles interacting
via a potential
that only depends on their relative
position
the first step is to realize that this
new set of variables behave
like the usual position and momentum in
quantum mechanics
in the sense that they obey the standard
canonical commutation relations
like for the original set all
commutation relations are zero apart
from
the three for the center of mass
variables along the first
axis the second axis
and the third axis and the equivalent
three for the relative variables
starting with the first axis and the
second
and the third
to check that these computational
relations are true let's use the
commutator of
x with px as an example
first we insert the definition of x in
terms of the original variables and
then the definition of px in terms of
the original variables
we can expand this communicator to get
first the common factors
and then four terms proportional to
various commutators
the first one between the position and
momentum of the first particle
the next is between the position of the
first particle and the momentum of the
second particle
next between the position of the second
particle and the momentum of the first
particle
and finally one between the position and
momentum
of the second particle we can cancel
this commutator and this commutator
because they are between different
particles so they're equal to zero
this one is i h bar and
so is this one putting everything
together the original commutator
finally gives i h bar and this confirms
this first computation relation here
the rest are equally simple and you can
work through the derivations yourselves
if you want to get some practice
overall we can work in terms of the
original coordinates given by this
collection of 12 operators obeying
three canonical computation relations or
in terms of this new set
of 12 operators which also obey the
corresponding canonical computation
relations
this type of change of variable is
extremely useful as we will see
in the rest of this video
we're now ready to look at the
hamiltonian of our system
we have the kinetic energy of particle
one the kinetic energy of particle two
and then their interaction energy which
depends on the relative position of the
two
particles before we move on we need an
important clarification about notation
if you've already seen the video on
tensor products
then you will know that this hamiltonian
acts on the state space w
of the two particle system which is
given by the tensor product
of the state space w1 of the first
particle
and the state space w2 of the second
particle
now when we spell out the hamiltonian
like this in terms of
three terms then each of these terms
must also
act on that same tensor product state
space
to be precise this means that the
kinetic energy operator of the first
particle
should really involve the tensor product
of p1
squared with the identity in w2
and the kinetic energy operator of the
second particle
should have the corresponding tensor
product
while these expressions involving tensor
products with identity operators
are the technically correct expressions
we typically use the shorthand
where we omit the identity operators and
the tensor product
and simply use this expression for
particle one
and this expression for particle 2.
this is the convention that i'm going to
use today moving forward
and only go back to the full expressions
when necessary
before we move on if you have not heard
about tensor products before
i would really encourage you to check
out our video on tensor products right
now
it's a very important topic when we
consider systems of more than
one quantum particle so for now let's
make some room and go back
to the problem at hand we want to
rewrite this hamiltonian in terms of the
center of mass and relative variables
for the kinetic energy terms let's first
consider the square of the momentum of
particle 1
using the expression that we derived
earlier about
this momentum in terms of the center of
mass and relative momentum
we can rewrite it like this we can now
calculate the square
and we get three terms one proportional
to the square of the center of mass
momentum
the other proportional to the relative
momentum
and then in principle we would get two
cross terms
but we can combine them into one because
the center of mass momentum variables
commute
with the relative momentum variables
using a similar derivation we can
rewrite
the square of the momentum of the second
particle as
a term proportional to the total
momentum squared
a term proportional to the relative
momentum squared and
a cross term we can now go back to our
full kinetic energy which is the sum of
the kinetic energy of particle one
and the kinetic energy of particle two
using the expressions that we just
derived
we start by combining the total momentum
terms here
and here we get this pre-factor
multiplied by the total momentum squared
next we combine the relative momentum
terms here and here
and we now get this pre-factor times the
relative momentum squared
the cross terms here and here cancel
because of this minus sign
and you might want to stop here for a
moment pause the video and just cross
check that you're happy with these tips
right moving on this here is the total
mass of the system
and this here is the reduced mass of the
system
putting everything together we can
rewrite our full hamiltonian in terms of
a kinetic energy term
that depends on the total mass of the
system and the total momentum squared
another kinetic energy term that depends
on
the reduced mass of the system and the
relative momentum squared
and we cannot forget the potential
energy term
which is trivial to rewrite in terms of
the new coordinates
its argument is simply the relative
coordinate
let's take a step back and see what
we've accomplished
by changing coordinates the original
hamiltonian has these three terms
when we rewrite it in terms of the new
center of mass
and relative coordinates we also get
three terms
in both cases we have two kinetic energy
terms associated with each type of
momentum
in the original expression the kinetic
energy terms depend on particle 1 of
mass
m1 here and particle 2 of
mass m2 here and in the new expression
we also have two kinetic energies the
first
one here looks like the kinetic energy
of a particle of
mass capital m the sum of the masses of
the original particles
and is given in terms of the center of
mass momentum
capital p the second here looks like the
kinetic energy of a particle of mass mu
the reduced mass of the two original
particles and depends
on the relative momentum this result is
really extremely
important looking at the kinetic
energies of the transformed hamiltonian
mathematically they look like the
kinetic energies of two particles
one of mass capital m and the other of
mass mu
so if this is what the math tells us we
can then also extend this to the
conceptual level
we can think of this system in terms of
the original
two real particles of masses m1 and
m2 or equivalently
in terms of two new fictitious particles
of masses m and mu
the question you will probably have at
this point is
why would we want to think in terms of
these
two fictitious particles rather than in
terms
of the original particles and the reason
is
the potential term while in the original
expression
the potential energy depended on both
position coordinates r1
and r2 the potential energy in the new
expression only depends on the relative
coordinate
r and this is critical because
while the two original particles
interact with each other
the two new fictitious particles do not
and this makes the solution of the
problem much simpler
because we've transformed it from a
problem of two real interacting
particles
to a problem of two fictitious
non-interacting particles in practice
this means that we can now
separate the hamiltonian into two
non-interacting terms
we define a center of mass hamiltonian
that only has a kinetic energy term
and we can define a relative hamiltonian
that has both a kinetic and a potential
energy term
the first hamiltonian describes a
fictitious particle of mass equal to the
sum of the masses of the two particles
and moving freely in space or to put it
another way
it describes the behavior of the center
of mass of the system
the second hamiltonian describes another
fictitious particle
whose mass is equal to the reduced mass
of the original particles
and is subject to this potential energy
it describes
the relative motion of the system about
the center of mass
the total hamiltonian is simply the sum
of these two hamiltonians and describes
the two fictitious particles
simultaneously
but they crucially don't interact with
each other
the next topic is therefore why
separable hamiltonians such as this one
are so much easier to work with than
hamiltonians
with an interaction term let's consider
a state-space wcom
which is the space where the center of
mass hamiltonian lives hence the acronym
com and let's also consider its
eigenvalue equation
where these are the eigenvalues and
these are the eigenstates
let's separately consider a space w
rel which is where the relative
hamiltonian lives
and this is its eigenvalue equation with
the eigenvalues here
and the eigenstates here
we can now construct the state space w
which is the tensor product of wcom with
w rail
the full hamiltonian h lives in this
tensor product space
and this is its eigenvalue equation
where these are the eigenvalues and
these are the eigenstates
what i want to show now is that we can
build
the eigenvalues and eigenstates of the
full hamiltonian here
from the eigenvalues and eigenstates of
the individual hamiltonians here and
here
which means that we can build the
solution of the two particle system
by only solving two separate one
particle systems
in particular we will show that we can
write the eigenstate psi
as the tensor product of the eigenstates
of the center of mass hamiltonian
and of the relative hamiltonian and that
we can write the total energy e
as the sum of the center of mass energy
and
the relative energy to see this
we will first show that the tensor
product state
is indeed the eigen state of the full
hamiltonian
we therefore start by writing the full
hamiltonian acting on the tensor product
state
we next expand the hamiltonian into two
separate terms
still acting on the tensor product state
and from the video on tensor products we
know that this term will
now only act on this part of the tensor
product
as this is simply the eigenvalue
equation for the center of mass
hamiltonian
we simply get the eigenvalue times the
state
similarly this term will only act on
this part of the tens product
and again it corresponds to the
eigenvalue equation of the relative
hamiltonian
so we get the corresponding eigenvalue
times
the state we can take out the tensor
product as a common factor
and we get this overall this confirms
that the tensor product state
is an eigenstate of the full hamiltonian
so we can indeed write the eigenstate
psi
as this tensor product and we also
immediately see
that the eigenvalue is simply the sum of
the eigenvalues of
the two separate hamiltonians here
overall this means that solving these
two separate eigenvalue problems is
enough to then build the solution to the
full hamiltonian up here
the eigenvalues are simply the sum of
the two original eigenvalues and the
eigen states are the tensor products
of the original eigenstates and this is
why
working in terms of the two fictitious
non-interacting particles
is more convenient than working in terms
of the real interacting particles
so we can solve the two parts of this
hamiltonian separately
let's start with the center of mass
hamiltonian here
we can write the hamiltonian as simply
given by the kinetic energy of the
center of mass
in the position representation the
kinetic energy term becomes this
and remember that the laplacian is
obtained from the gradient
and in the case of the center of mass
variables it is
explicitly given by this
putting things together we get this
eigenvalue equation in the positioned
representation
where i'm using the standard notation
for eigenfunctions
this is the eigenvalue equation of a
free particle of mass capital m
and from the corresponding video we know
that the eigenfunctions
are given by plane waves like this
and the eigen energies span a continuous
spectrum that has
a dispersion proportional to the
momentum squared
overall this means that the center of
mass behaves like a free particle
and this hamiltonian simply describes
translations of the system
as a whole with all the energy being in
the form
of kinetic energy we can therefore solve
the
behavior of the center of mass once and
for all
and we've just done it
let's now turn to the relative
hamiltonian here if we copy it
we now remember that this hamiltonian
has a kinetic energy part
and a potential energy part and again
working in the position representation
we can rewrite it like this
the laplacian is again obtained from the
gradient which in this case of the
relative variables is given
by this expression putting everything
together we get
this eigenvalue equation in the position
representation
unlike the case of the center of mass
hamiltonian
for the eigenvalue equation of the
relative hamiltonian
we cannot provide a once and for all
solution
this is because of this potential term
here which will take a different form
for different systems so to fully solve
the problem of two interacting quantum
particles
we've now gone as far as we can go
without specifying the form
of the interaction potential for
specific examples i refer you to our
videos
linked in the description for example
those on the hydrogen atom
where this interaction is given by the
coulomb potential
however before we conclude there is in
fact one special case
in which we can take one extra step
and this is the case when the potential
v
does not depend generally on the
relative position of the two particles
but in fact only depends on their
relative
distance and by that i mean the
magnitude
of the relative coordinate at this point
you will probably all recognize this
potential it is the central potential
this means that what we learned about
the motion for single particle in the
central potential
in the corresponding videos can be
directly used
to describe the relative motion of two
particles interacting
via a potential that only depends on the
distance between the two particles
you may wonder whether this is the
situation that we ever encounter
and the answer is a resounding yes
the coulomb potential is an example of
an interaction between two particles
that only depends on the distance
between the particles
a very good way to see this in action is
to check out our videos on the hydrogen
atom
in which a proton and an electron
interact precisely via
the coulomb potential from our
discussion today
this means that although the hydrogen
atom is a two particle problem
the relevant physics described by the
relative motion of the proton
and the electron it's effectively a one
particle problem
and furthermore it is the problem of one
particle
moving in a central potential
so overall we've arrived at a rather
neat result
we started with a system of two
complicated
interacting quantum particles in which
the interaction
only depends on the relative position of
the two particles
we've then found that we can separate
this into two different problems
one for the motion of one fictitious
particle which moves as a free particle
whose mass is a total mass of the system
and
which describes the center of mass
motion of the system
and the second as the motion of another
fictitious particle
whose mass is the reduced mass of the
system
which describes the relative motion of
the two original particles
this is pretty useful because rather
than having to solve the original
problem of two interacting particles
we now have two separate problems of two
non-interacting fictitious particles
which are
much easier to solve today we've laid
the groundwork to study systems of two
interacting particles as a good example
of such a system i would encourage you
to
watch our video on the hydrogen atom and
as always if you liked the video please
subscribe